foreign
[Music]
assisted strategies to design cell
culture processes most of the work comes
from the phds uses of Johannes Muller
and it's my pleasure to present his
resolve
in process development we usually start
with selection of
self-trained for production of a certain
uh therapeutic antibody or any other
biopharmace vertical but then when it
comes to process development we start
with optimization of culture conditions
medium composition if we apply fact
strategies and we have to
elaborate these strategies we have to
optimize them and finally we have to
perform the scale up from a small scale
to the production scale and the state of
the article that mostly experimental
methods are applied for example to sign
up experiment strategies
these are in many cases quite time
consuming and uh
also costs a lot of money and our idea
is
to use modern assisted tools
to save time
and then of course
to save money doing process development
and that's what I want to share with you
today
so first I will introduce our model
assisted design of experiment concept
and then I will discuss this concept for
optimization or process parameters and
doing your scale up and I will summarize
my talk and give a short Outlook
yeah most of you might know the concept
of a sign of experiments a concept which
is intended to perform experiments
based to a strict plan usually you have
factors that you want to investigate
several factors like subset
concentration temperature oxygen
concentration pH
and you use a pre-selected design space
for for these factors and
she experiments or the experimental plan
is designed according to a fixed team
usually it takes a lot of experiments
and the main problem here is to define
the design space correctly
on the other hand
we have
process models
for example models for sale growth which
are bullets in product formation and to
set up a real
good model requires a lot of prior
knowledge you usually you have to
perform a lot of very specific
experiments and then of course
which is models you can try to optimize
your your process in Silicon
what we want to do is to com you want to
combine these two words by using
a kinetic process model and use this to
pre-calculate the experimental space in
a doe so
we incorporate knowledge that is already
at hand
especially at the beginning of a good of
a design process then we select
appropriate design spaces with the help
of this model and finally we of course
ex perform experiment but
significantly reduced number of
experiments in the pre-selected science
place
the doe concept starts of course with
some initial cultivations you need some
information you need some data about the
process which you can use to set up the
mathematical model and to set up the uh
the DOE
you can have to select a certain type of
doe
then of course uh we go into the
simulation and the evaluation of the
design of experiment plan
we can go several perform several rounds
here and then we get recommendations for
the experiments we want to perform uh
this will be performed of course and
data from this experiment and can be
used again to
to modify the model to improve the model
and in the end we have a set of
experiments we have optimized process
parameters and in parallel we have the
mathematical model that can be used as a
starting point for digital twin for
further process development
it is
but uh
this concept requires a well elaborated
workflow and this workflow starts with a
definition of the task so we have to
Define what kind of cell line we we need
uh what is the culture system what is
the medium what are important process
parameters medium composition
temperature pH uh oxygen concentration
of modality or whatever
and then targets have to be defined this
can be more than one of course one
important Target is a maximum title of
the the of the product but there can be
other quality attributes
um that might have an impact on the
quality uh of the product and these have
to be considered as well
then we have to check what do we know
already about our process we have to
perform a data analysis so we have to to
look at prior data what do we know
already do we know already some course
effect relationships for example impact
of glucose concentration on the growth
rate
uh if not we have to go into the
literature or maybe we have to perform
specific experiments if required
and with these informations we go into
the modeling process so based on
cultivation data or uh for your
knowledge you can set up the model uh
for this course effect relationships
we want to keep the model structure as
simple as possible because especially at
the beginning of a design process we
have not have too many data at hand for
determination of the model parameters
therefore it's better to start with
quite simple models now this is model we
go into the
um
simulation of the doe here first we can
select different due strategies and
factorial design and de-optimally design
and e-optimal design or whatever and we
can select
um the the appropriate design space
and with this selection we go finally
into the
um
experiments that are performed and
hopefully with your Jewish number of
experiments
I will show this concept for foreign
strategy
um we performed for production of an
antibody with Cho cells the cell line
was provided by too much noise from the
University of Philadelphia
and this consists of two parts the first
one is the
modulus is the design of the medium
and fat bird strategy and then the
transfer into the scale up
um this
transfer was performed by the group of
Virginia data eyeball by janmuller it's
a
um
inspiration
so the first step is medium optimization
and this is of course not
a complete optimization we focused on
the main compounds glucose and glutamine
because the medium was already quite
quite well
performing so it was just let's say it
is
a final checking of the medium
um this optimization was done in the
batch process and and we use this
um problem as a proof of concept so in
the first case we we set up the liquid
UE then we performed the same
experiments in parallel probably a lot
more than than what's required but I
will come back to this later and we
evaluated since the targets we have set
and then of course the question is could
we really save some experiments in the
end
so the first step was to set up a model
engineer we were lucky to to uh that we
could work with
a model that was at hand we have
developed these models uh over the years
um in different studies it is a quite
simple model it's an unstructured
non-sacral Gadget model where we uh
basically
have to cause effect relationships
between the growth rate and gross cell
growth cell just and glucose but I mean
um the consumption like that ammonia
production and say the antibody
production
to give you an idea of this this model
is set up here we have here the on the
left side see the balance equations for
biomass viable total cell density
viability you have the sub bio balance
equation for substrate metabolites
um and here for the product and we have
the kinetic equations uh you can see
mostly consisting of monu type equations
so nothing really special but the idea
was to keep the model as simple as
possible because in the beginning of the
cultivation or the beginning of a
process development to not have that
many experiments at hand to identify the
parameters of the model properly
we have used four Shake plant
experiments for for parameter fitting
and this is just an example uh for the
cell density and and the antibody
concentration and in both cases we got a
quite good fits
um and similar fits we got for our
glucose glutamine ammonia lactate
concentration and the product
concentration
we
choose the optimal design which is used
quite often for this kind of problems
you can also choose another one or you
can first start with a selection of uh
of a design
um
in this case
as already mentioned to optimize glucose
and glutamine concentration so glucose
was varied between 20 and 60 million
more per liter and good I mean between 2
and 12 millimole per liter and then of
course for for each point the time
course
um
for this is this culture was calculated
for a batch culture of course uh here we
have Society density Against Time and
this is already one advantage of this
mod assisted approach because you don't
do not only get values for a certain
time point you get the whole time course
and you see here for example the maximal
cell density for each in each case is a
different time points
yeah so
um you can use this data to to plot the
the uh
quite common with
one surface plot
here for the the cell density the luxury
concentration antibody concentration
ammonia concentration and here you see
that that you get different pictures for
the the four mentioned
factors so for the maximal
the cell concentration uh you get a
maximum at the highest uh group cause
and glutamine concentration for the
antibody concentration at the the
glutamine concentration
um
seems to have an impact not the glucose
concentration but for lactate
the glutamine concentration
the glucose concentration is important
for ammonia the glutamine concentration
so if you just ask for the the antibody
concentrations and of course an Optimum
would be somewhere as high substrate
concentration but if you look at the the
the the metabolites especially uh
and if you want to reduce uh this
concentration of this is this metabolite
then
is probably required to select other
combinations of the the subset
concentration so
and to combine
these these different targets
uh in one value one way is to define a
so-called desirability function and in
this is our ability
um
function for for each variable
you define a range between a lower and
uh and an upper limit and you can Define
the constraints for this
so you get a liability value for for
each
um variable and you can combine this in
an overall desirability uh by by a
simple the sum of these individual ones
the constraints in this case
are well the cell density should be
larger than 10 to the 7 cells per
milliliter the antibody concentration
should be at a maximum selected
concentration should feel below 30
millimo per liter and T ammonia
concentration should be at minimum
and with the height of the child is our
ability function you get a design space
it looks completely different than than
what we had before so what you can see
here is uh in that that has a huge range
in in blue whether desirability is is
close to zero so it it's not worth to
perform any experiments in this range
and we only have a certain range which
is indicated here in in green
um where the desirability uh
is sufficient and and high enough and
then you can set your your boundaries or
your design space within this range and
that's what we did
so uh
um we use this this is modified design
space and simulated again
um the the optimal design in this range
and here we perform the same experiments
experimentally to to see if we get the
same conclusions as from this uh
simulated
design space and what you can see is
that the shape is completely the same so
we have a maximum at the highest glucose
concentration and the lowest glutamine
concentration and finally and and really
required to sign space would be quite
small as indicated here and that would
be the range where you should perform
your experiment
in the second step we optimize the
fatbast strategy uh here we have some
some more variables we have the the feed
rate it's the bonus feed uh we have put
a mean and glucose concentration in the
feed and we have the starting time of
the feed so
more complex
approach and again we first uh perform
JZ
draw some conclusion for the
experimental design
in this case we used an e-optimal design
in total 29 experiments and this
corruption just solves one example uh
the relationship between the total feed
rate and the concentration of glucose a
greater mean in the feed and on the
right side you see the surface response
plots and again we see that we have a
range for the optimum for the cell
density we have a quite broad range uh
for the for the antibody concentration
not really in a very sharp maximum and
of course we see a range where we have
a very high ammonia concentrations which
should be omitted in this case we did
not look at the lactate concentration
too much because it it remained below a
critical levels
and again we
calculated the the perspective
desirability function and here we could
see that
um
yeah at High
feat rates and
low glutamine concentration in this case
an Optimum for the desirability could be
found and
is this finding was confirmed
experimentally in Shake flowers with I
don't want to to show this too much in
detail
truly could prove that the UE concept uh
is able to reduce the the experimental
effort uh
to quite some extent
so next step was can we use his model
assistance strategy for further scale up
so we wanted to to perform a scale up
from 250 milliliter to a 50 thing 50
liter bioreactor single use bioreactor
and as already mentioned this all were
performed
Etc in theory
but we only wanted to to see if we get
the
um a good scale up but we wanted to see
if there are changes
um in in the identified parameters uh
which in the different scale which is
quite quite important uh if we want to
use a model that has been established on
a small scale also in larger scales
so at first uh we modified the model we
selected some scale up criteria uh the
UN card Generations were performed on
the different scales and then the model
parameters were
identified but not only
um once but
um which we wanted to to know something
about the model uncertainty for this we
use the Monte Carlo use the Monte Carlo
method for a termination of the process
variability and finally this was
eventual evaluated statistically
all right
as already mentioned
SQL app from 80 milliliter Shake flask
to a 50 liter product
pilot scales
size
the first question was uh can we use the
scale up Criterion for for the steroids
for steering
and for this cfp simulations were
performed by anmuller and
we used a
power to volume Criterium for scale up
in this case the value of 90 watt per
cubic meter
foreign
cultures
um I performed in in 80 milliliter shade
plus
um
crashes so next step was uh 250
milliliter two liter and
yeah the the representative results and
what we can see is that the
shape of the the curve from the cell
density is quite similar but not only
the shape but also the the uh
model description and especially if we
look at the see the uncertainties we
associate the uncertainty band in both
cases we see either the cultures could
be described very well in both scales
but as already mentioned we compared
this is the parameter setup will
identified in both cases with the Monte
Carlo method to see if there are changes
in the in the parameter distributions
and what we can see here is uh for the
the for some
parameters of the model the growth rate
okay for the for which I mean okay for
ammonia glucose and yield quarters
coefficient ammonia but I mean and
update grade for glutamine production
rates for antibodies that there's only
one case a significant difference here
for the for ammonia but more other cases
there's no uh significant difference in
the in the parameter distributions for
the
um
a termite model parameters
so when the final step we went to the 50
liter scale and again we have to buy
quite good fit between the experimental
parameters and the model parameters and
this shows as a strategy uh setting up
a model in a very early stage of the
process development here in the case in
in Shake flowers and transferring this
this model
in a digital twin uh to two larger
scales worked perfectly
this slide summarizes a little bit the
the strategy and shows uh the people
that were involved in development this
is especially this workflow that this
was a project uh funded by the bmvf and
with our friends in
in lemgo
but group of young from and
um
in
in Fort Wayne with a group of professors
we were able to to develop this workflow
yeah to summarize my talk
um I hope I could convince you that this
mdoe concept is very well you have a
tool for process development we can
combine modeling and statistic
um
we use knowledge on the process to
reduce the the does the design space we
could reduce the number of experiments
significantly
um and we could apply it along the
Upstream process chain
with respect to scale up it was a
possible to use CD to define the scale
up Criterion power to volume Criterium
and we could scale up it successfully
from shape class to Pilot scale
and uh something that uh should not be
underestimated we learned a lot about
the process during this this development
especially when setting up the model so
we have a tremendous increase in process
knowledge
I have to acknowledge
um our partners again and the funding
agencies especially the MDF and I thank
you for your intention
thank you very much